oui par elle me parle souvent de vous
bien euh on va entendre une une jolie
chanson maintenant je vais vous demander
de bien vouloir regagner votre place
alors cette chanson est extraite de cet
album les aventures à l'eau et c'est
signé François Ardi ça s'appelle mon
ange écoutez Julien clair mon
[Musique]
ange tu rêvis d'un amour tout en soi
etour
que
maintenant je n'étais qu'un chasseur
capturant les cœurs volage don juant tu
as posé tes yeux le
ciel sur moi et j'ai vu les ailes d'un
ange de lumière à la sortie d'un
tunnel bel an mon ange mélange se vange
se changeant
[Musique]
démon mon ange me mort me mange je suis
mort je suis
[Musique]
marron toi la petite fille sage qui a
peur de l'orage que per
maintenant jouer à la poupée doucement
te verser aimer tout le temps malgré
tout l'UR et tout le
miel de ton cœur si fidèle je suis pas
l'angeon du rêve ça non je descends pas
du
[Musique]
ciel je dérange mon ange je change quand
l'ange se
changeant
rison je décolle je m'envole je flameme
je flame je fais des
bons mon ange se fâche mon ange se cache
me lâche
de
bon mon ange que j'aime je t'ai fait de
la peine
noublion mon ange qui est signé François
hardardy je vais vous demander de nous
rejoindre juste un petit mot